excited to introduce you to our omix
logic training programs in nigeria
this program will help you see the role
of big data
and next generation sequencing
technologies in life sciences
omits logic bioinformatics training is
designed
for everyone interested to learn and
apply
data science skills to study biological
data sets
in an effective and meaningful way
before we get started let me introduce
you to our company vision
and team my name is beep shabaswas
and i am the omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are part of a bioinformatics
community managed by
pine biotech let me start by introducing
pine biotech the company behind
omix logic share with you details about
the upcoming omics logic programs and
explain
how the training resources we will
discuss today
will be used in the upcoming training
program
omixlogic is a program for
bioinformatics training
that was developed in collaboration
between
prime biotech and the etobi
bioinformatics research center
what we will discuss today and
throughout this program is a result of
hard work by an amazing team led by
company co-founders
dr alfred tober and dr leonid brodsky
dr tober comes from a medical background
and has extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support of many
research projects and initiatives that
support data science training and
applications
in medicine dr brodsky is the director
of the tuber bioinformatics research
center
at university of fifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team you see here
includes experts in bioinformatics
computer science and training and some
of our team will be presenting today as
well
over the course of the past several
years our team has been collaborating
with a number of
academic institutions around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omics logic programs have
been thoroughly evaluated
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes
importantly the programs are designed to
support students
with minimal bioinformatics background
including
biology and biomedical studies majors as
well as faculty
interested in bioinformatics data
science and
biomedical research the goal of the
omics logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and peer example developing
a growing community with shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
in life and data sciences
in this webinar our team will introduce
you to
resources that will get you started on
this journey we hope that
you will be able to benefit from this
webinar
the objective is to get you started so
let us go first to this url that you see
on your screen edu dot t hyphen bio dot
info uh dr mood if you can kindly post
the link
on the chat
so we would like for every one of you
to go to this link and sign up
if you are already signed in and you
already have an account
then please login to your account and
keep
and be logged into your account through
the rest of this process
because we will be showing you how to go
about with the different resources
during the course of this session today
and if you have been able to sign up
please put one in the chat box
so that i can understand that you have
actually signed up to this portal
or you are already logged in
thank you dr mohit and aditya for
sharing the link
has anybody been able to sign up
or login to the portal
okay so moving on
as you can see you will be able to login
using your username and password
or also connect using any of your social
media profiles i see already francis
and somaya has done this
so as we progress with our session today
please make sure that you're already
signed into this site it is a free
registration
now moving on we are excited
that this event has been let and
organized by our dedicated team
in nigeria that brings together experts
who have an
interest in data driven research and
have all recently completed
our specialized training they are now
certified and ready to assist all of you
in joining the program getting
registered finding all the necessary
resources and helping you
troubleshoot any technical or conceptual
challenges you come across
the program will also be supported by a
team in the u.s and india
dr harpreet kaur is a certified omics
logic trainer and expert by information
who will guide the hands-on sessions dr
mohit mazumdar is our omics logic
project mentor
elia brodsky is spine biotic co-founder
and ceo
i will now pass it on to elia to talk
about the increasing significance of
data science in biomedical research
and introduce you to the types of
challenges we will be addressing in this
upcoming program
thank you very much beepside and let me
share my screen
and welcome everyone to this webinar
it's exciting to see that so many of you
were able
to join and beeps as i'm going through
some of these slides please
be ready with the questionnaire so that
we can get to know some of our
participants
so today we are here to discuss
bioinformatics and the natural question
is
what is bioinformatics and the truth is
that bioinformatics is this
intersection between informatics
technologies
or data science statistical analysis
and analytical approaches
and a focus on biological data
and biological data is unique data it's
not just
data like uh marketing data or finance
data they're very special types of data
that we
have to know how to process prepare and
manage effectively
when it comes to bioinformatics so the
bioinformatics approach
is the intersection of all three and a
lot of people confuse bioinformatics
with computer science
or with biotechnology but it's actually
right there in between
so let's take a look at some of these
data sets and try to think about
how has the nature of data in biology
changed since the development
of next generation sequencing
technologies or high
throughput technologies since the
uh project for the human genome
there has been an exponential growth in
the
types of data and the types of
applications
of big data in biotechnology
in biological research biomedical
research in clinical applications
so there has been this challenge of big
data
which is heterogeneous or diverse types
of data
which are growing in the number of
samples
and the size per sample and also
it is a continuous uh inclusion of
new types of variations so we go from
cell lines to
animal models to patients now patients
around the world
sequenced around different continents
different ethnic backgrounds
different diets different conditions etc
etc so it's really an
exponential growth of complexity and a
good way to look at this
is to see how this has changed
since this new pandemic so in this new
pandemic
we have seen a tremendous growth of
publicly available
genomes for the source code ii virus as
compared to some of the previous
pandemics like sars
ebola virus mers and zika and what we
see today
is that even the general public is aware
of the genomic properties like new
mutations they understand the different
proteins they understand how they
interact with the host
and here we are coming from a biological
or biomedical background
and have now access to all of these
amazing data sets
that we can leverage to conduct our own
research
so what types of biological phenomena
could be studied
with omix data when we think about omics
data
we are really talking about a number of
different
types of omics data for example
we can think about phenotypic data or
phenomics
phenotypic data describes the external
characteristics of cells
tissues and organisms so we can use
clinical data to
collect phenomic data we can use imaging
we can
use any kind of an external
characterization
of whatever tissue and samples we're
studying
and then we have what's called genomic
data genomic data
characterizes the dna code and dna code
could have
a number of different variations that
include single nucleotide variations or
single nucleotide polymorphisms
it includes copy number variation
different types of repeats and segments
that are
that are studied separately then
we can also look at epigenomic data
epigenomic data
includes data that characterizes
different epigenetic regulation
mechanisms
for example we can think about whole
genome
methylation patterns so how is dna
methylated
or how is the chromatin condensed or
expanded so that you can actually
express some of those accessible regions
and that is being studied through
immunoprecipitation so many different
technologies
and ultimately we can also think about
the transcriptomic data or data that
describes
gene expression and that gene expression
could be
different levels of gene expression
different types of transcripts
as a result of alternative splicing
so you can see that just using next
generation sequencing we have access to
a whole range of data types that we can
study
and the key factor about all of these
types of data
is that all of these types of data have
to be processed
so when we talk about whole exome or
whole genome sequencing
when we talk about dna methylation and
chipseek
rnaseq metagenomics proteomics
metabolomics
one key factor in all of these data sets
is they have to be prepared for analysis
they have to be processed
so we have to understand what is the
data that is being collected
how to process it so that we can
separate signal from noise
and then what are some of the downstream
analysis
options and biological interpretation so
this program
that we're introducing in this webinar
is going to focus
on addressing all of these different
topics by giving you
a broad introduction to a variety of
different types of omics data
and giving you resources and tools so
that you can learn more
in depth about each one of these and
understand how to apply them in the
context of a practical
project so the program that we're
introducing today will consist of
three important elements first one we
will have
interactive sessions just like we have
today we will meet on zoom
we will discuss some of these omix data
types and we will
look at how to practically analyze such
data
the second part of the program are the
self-study uh
materials that you can find on that
portal that beeps i just mentioned and
you have signed up
you will find there such resources as
introduction to bioinformatics
transcriptomics training that includes
four different courses
genomics training metagenomics training
and many others
importantly these are not just
theoretical materials but they're also
facilitated by practical exercises
on our t bioinfo platform the platform
is guided by artificial intelligence to
enable you to conduct big data analysis
research
in the context of very specific types of
data sets
but it doesn't end there we also will
include practical assignments
in coding so those of you that are more
interested in the data science and the
application of data science to these
types of biological data sets
we will give you access to some
practical coding exercises so that you
can also leverage
such practices as coding in r and python
to investigate some of these data sets
so let's take a look
at how you can learn about some of these
omix data sets
and give you some examples that you can
kind of experience what will happen
during the program itself so the first
thing that we'll do
in the program is we'll give you an
introduction of some of these
computational tools
and data sets that you can leverage to
do that
let me go to the tea bioinfo platform
that we will talk about throughout this
course and
throughout this webinar so if you can go
together with me
to server dot t bio dot info
please let me know once you are there
you will find here that you have
access to many different types of omics
processing pipelines including mass spec
data
structural biology data and downstream
analysis sections for example we'll take
a look today
at an example pipeline for processing
rna-seq
or transcriptomic data once you get to
this example we're going to just do a
demo so don't worry about uploading
any files and i know that many of you
don't have access to this
but you will have access once you join
the program
and if you would like to have a demo
account you can go ahead and request a
demo account
right here using this access form
so once you start the process of
analysis you need to prepare the
reads or the raw data that is coming out
of the sequencer
once you have prepared you will find a
couple of options that are available for
pre-processed
reads then we can quantify
by mapping on transcripts and preparing
a
table of expression and once that table
of expression is prepared
you will find the results in the output
section right here so now
we are ready to do downstream analysis
now
this platform is a big part of what we
are trying to do because
for anyone without any technical
background you can get
get access to these advanced
computational tools
to study a variety of different types of
data sets
so again as beeps have mentioned an
important part of what we are trying to
do
on this webinar is to get you started we
want you to sign up
on these different resources that we are
going to be discussing throughout the
session
so that when the program starts you're
all ready to get going
so hopefully by now you have signed up
on the educational portal
i just showed you the practical analysis
pipeline where you can request
access or if you have already joined the
program registration and have completed
it
that account will be sent to you and in
a few slides i will introduce you to
another resource where you can learn
about coding
but let's talk about how can these
different resources help you study
for example genomic data the human
genome is over 3 billion base pairs long
with over 20 000 genes and many
unexplored
dark matter sections junk dna that is
still being studied
learning about the impact of variants
like single point polymorphisms
copy number variation and even repeats
is still a challenge
that many teams around the world are
studying and exploring
so knowing that each sample is a huge
data set that has
to be separated from commonly found
variations and unique variations that
could be associated
between the variants and the phenotypes
and so to help you
understand what goes into preparing such
data
sequencing it and then measuring some
accumulation of mutations in conditions
like
cancer or phenotype or haplotype based
on population
you can find a number of different
pipelines that we will discuss
and that are in detail explained in the
introduction to genomics
genomics 1 and genomics 2 courses
we'll also cover an important section of
transcriptomics that i just showed you
an example of
where you will find processing pipelines
data preparation techniques
analysis and exploration of variation
between
different samples and such common
approaches for biological hypothesis
testing like differential gene
expression
and pathway and gene set analysis and
enrichment
we'll also talk about metagenomics where
we
understand the type of microbiome
by studying the sequences of 16s
ribosomal rna
to understand the microbiome by looking
at the diversity and composition between
different groups of samples so we'll
actually take a look at some healthy
microbiome for example in a citizen
science project called american gut
and also think about how can microbiome
play a role
in multiple different conditions these
conditions can be subtle
like actively exercising or inactively
exercising
maybe sensitivity to different types of
foods
or even such diseases like cancer
when we talk about treatment or
alzheimer's disease when we talk about
the condition of the brain and the brain
microbiome or how the microbiome in the
gut
could be associated with the health of
our
mental and psychological condition so
all of these
exciting tutorials and projects are
described
in the educational portal and then you
will have access
to interactive sessions where our
mentors will be describing these
projects in detail
and helping guide you through the
process of analysis
now you've probably heard about another
paradigm shift
in the area of big data and that has to
do with machine learning
analytics and data science and so we
understand
that the challenge for many people to
start getting used to this concept
of data driven research is that a lot of
times we have access to data
without a predefined hypothesis but what
we do have
is access to a data set tools that can
help us
explore patterns and then convert those
patterns
into a specific training for
a computer to learn from and so we've
introduced
a number of data science resources and
coding challenges that will help you get
started with
r and python to kind of show you what
that will look like
let's go to another resource that is
going to be used
throughout the session so we've looked
at the educational portal we have looked
at
the server big data platform and now
let's go to code.omicslogic.com
and this is also a website that we
use throughout the web the upcoming
program
and you can log in and create an account
here for free
so once you get here you will see a
place to sign up
and once you're signed up you will gain
access to courses
so throughout this program we'll touch
on many of the
code examples that you can then modify
to make sure that once you've explored
the data you can also present
your analysis results in the context of
what you are trying to do
with effective visualization and
analytical tools
as an example we have here a couple of
courses
that are for introduction to data
science
in r and in python and all of this
information is linked to the different
types
of examples that are being covered
in the educational materials that we
will review
throughout this program it starts from
very basic stuff
you just load files explore the files
understand different data types
and goes all the way to advanced machine
learning methods
that you will gain access to as you
register for the program
and vipsa will explain at the end of
this session how to complete your
registration so that you get access
to both free and premium resources in
the context of this full program
so another resource that i encourage all
of you to already sign up for
and try it out so how will all of this
work in the context of this program
in the context of this program we will
cover six
different sessions and you will have
access
for the period of this whole program to
all of these different resources
and get guidance on how to use them
effectively
in these sessions we'll start by
introducing
next generation sequencing a major data
type that has
completely transformed molecular biology
biotechnology
agriculture neuroscience oncology and
many other domains
we'll talk about how bioinformatics and
big data
is playing a role in biomedical research
and practice
we'll then talk about the synchronous
courses that are
around collections of data for genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and others
we'll cover some of these practical
steps of analysis
in detail and then we'll introduce you
to important project examples that you
can try on your own
developing your practical skills and
seeing how they are applied by
experts to address specific challenges
in big data sets
importantly these resources are all
linked together
so what you see here is the overall
process that we have
tried and refined over the course of the
past
couple of years with thousands of
participants from around the world
all of these types of programs are
structured in the following way
your activity from all of these
platforms from the
server platform from the educational
portal from the coding challenges
is aggregated into your individual
profile
and as a group we go through sessions
where as you can see
the yellow here represents the
educational materials
the gray represents the practical
analytical pipelines
and the pink right here represents
coding exercises
so you'll see how all of these materials
together will help you
go from an observer that understands the
different challenges
projects and data types to then
practically apply them in the context of
predefined examples and then get
introduced to
independent projects that you can
develop into a
research study of your own for example
just recently we have done a number of
programs
around africa where we had multiple
participants taking a look
at some of the courses like what you're
looking at today
introduction to bioinformatics
transcriptomics and others
and then look at such projects examples
as
the ebola project and the origins and
pathogenesis of the novel coronavirus so
a project
that helps us explore variation at the
genomic level of these pathogens and try
to find association with specific
phenotypes
like how it spreads among the population
how it causes disease etc importantly we
had
many different types of participants
these participants
included graduate students undergraduate
students faculty
and clinicians and in many ways what we
have
created is an experience that combines
multiple elements
and translates into more than just a
certificate that you would get from
another place like coursera
or edx or maybe even your university
because
it is a certificate that is based on
practical hands-on experience
and you take away from this experience
not just the educational understanding
but a practical resource and a community
that you can continue and grow with
even after the program is over so at
this time
i'm going to pass it back to our nigeria
team facilitators adekunle
at the tile to discuss
what their experience was and i'll let
beeps introduce you
to our team in nigeria please go ahead
thank you
for the overview
so joining us from nigeria our
collaborators and facilitators
is adekunle de lavoy he is a nomics
logic
uh trainer and a faculty at leeds city
university in nigeria
adidas is a faculty at the department of
oral diagnostic
sciences at bairo university in nigeria
and hamza sani is a medical laboratory
scientist at the university of
lagos in nigeria now i would like to
invite adi kunle
to speak more about the program and his
experience
thank you very much um gibson yes as
i've been introduced my name is adikulia
deluway
i'm a faculty from luke city university
here in nigeria and also a mentor with
pine biotech
i have my background in medical
laboratory sciences i'm currently a
lecturer
body medical scientist nurses and
radiographers
my real focus is molecular biology and
genomics where i'm currently
completing a phd degree and i'm also
presently exploring opportunities in
bioinformatics and big data science
a fourier i've found very exciting and
fulfilling since coming to join the
prime biotech platform
i'm also currently part of the umis
logic nigerian team as a facilitator
and program director fine bartek
us is a bioinformatics company that is
working towards providing cutting-edge
bioinformatics research and
education in partnership with several
other universities
across the globe and one of such is the
prestigious live city university
here in ibadah nigeria as a previous
participant and alumnus of the pine
biotech program
i'm currently utilizing acquired
knowledge taking courses in
bioinformatics transcriptomic
metagenomics
to study the variation in hygiene
testing converting enzyme 2 that is ac2
among male and female number as well as
cov19
subjects infected subjects as we all
know ac2 receptor binding is what the
cells go satisf
virus utilized in entry into the cells
to
infect the cells as
exciting as bioinformatics is the fact
is there is a computational resource gap
when it comes to successfully running
bioinformatics pipelines on data sets
and first is that big data science and
bioinformatics are infrastructure
demanding
as there is a need for high computing
power and space to be able to run these
pipelines
and just to to to add a perspective to
that
you can imagine you have a genomic data
set you want to
analyze and um it's about 300 gigabytes
um you know in size
i mean in this part of the world even
downloading this um
kind of data sets i mean file would be a
huge challenge not to talk of processing
and analyzing them
so um this is one of the challenges
we have when it comes to you know buying
formatting
i mean computational resources gap now
and this of course meant a huge
investment as the gadgets and resources
needed are very very expensive
there is also the inaccessibility issues
as well as the
wide gap in the expert is necessary to
carry on these tasks
are mentoring of those coming into
defeat despite the need for these key
cells
and this is where i find very very
interesting and helpful defined voltage
and cloud-based
ai guided server for participants to
utilize in their learning journey
aside the way structured asynchronous
courses and other learning resources
learners can immediately begin to have
hands-on experience on big data
analysis here on this slide is a screen
shot of my own personal
project pipelines i run using the
cloud-based ai guided t-server platform
during my learning experience
so the present covey 19 outbreak have
come not only to test the scientific
knowledge
and advancement of the past decades but
also it has come to show how important
these scientific breakthroughs
such as the next generation sequencing
and other molecular biology technologies
have become in helping to cope with the
present pandemic that creates the
very core of our human existence also
the next important
component that need equal even though
much more attention now
is key professionals are able to respond
adequately
to these opportunities and challenges
using bioinformatics
i therefore look forward to having many
more professionals
university faculty and researchers as
well as students
as boarding scientists and professionals
to key into this
opportunity that is available by
participating in the forthcoming busy
coming
mixed logic um training part one as well
as many other training programs that is
to follow
towards becoming an expert in this field
at this point i will equally want to
hand it over to my co-facilitator here
in nigeria
um dr aditya approached it to
say some few things also thank you
hello good good evening everybody i'm
aditya bushady
i'm a lecturer in the department of
dangerous sciences
in bio university county nigeria and i'm
also a post fellowship senior registrar
in all architectural pathology in
american technology in nigeria
by background i'm a dentist i'm by
by my clinic but by clicking based study
i'm an hypothetist i'm because
of the fact that i love to ask why
that's why i'm a pathologist and while
doing the course of my study
i was also able to see the immense
opportunities in data analysis and
molecular diagnostics
this is what actually attracted me to
bioinformatics as
a field and the fact that you can learn
a lot
from a patient by looking at data from
the past
and predict a prognosis of that patient
by the genetic signature of
the patient you can learn why they are
successful some diseases why they are
healed at times
and why they're for sick at times so is
this
interesting why aspect of disease that
made me become a pathologist in the
first place
and i found out that bioinformatics not
only helps to understand why but also
why not why are some people susceptible
to some diseases
why is that cancer in some diseases why
do some people smoke and get down with
lung cancer
and some other people smoke and don't
have any iota
of this casino genesis with the initial
workshops i took in
bioinformatics you first have to learn
the business of data analysis
you have to learn either how that python
before i can start
answering any project in bioinformatics
but one good thing about
the fireball tech is that you don't need
to spend months
learning data analysis don't spend
months learning our python
there is already a a cloud server
where the only thing you need to do is
follow the steps and
get the same results as if we are
performing by ourselves
at times when you are running these
pipelines in some
in some other websites it might take you
four or five days
to just get one under but
you can look at my own project pipeline
you can see that at times i want 45
pipelines
daily and that means in a couple of days
i get to get as many results as possible
i get to finish many projects
this is the advantage of this server dot
pipeline and that's why
we feel that for beginners for
undergraduates for learners for people
that are just
starting in both romantics the
about the the the server it's a
good way to start to learn
and that's why we feel that in ninja we
we need a set of
a set of academicians researchers like a
mix of this pipeline
to forward and to afford research in
both formatics
and all you also have a pluto of mentors
when i initially when i studied
bioinformatics
i could not find mentors to guide me in
the past i could not find people i could
talk to
about a research project or research
item but
but in in in in in
torah server in pybiotic that's not that
that's not the case
you have mentors both locally and
internationally so that
for each research project you have
assistance for each research tool
for each problem for each for for each
obstacle you have mentors to guide you
and that's why we we are glad that we
can actually
form a community in nigeria of
like-minded bioinformaticians or
people that have interest and passion in
bio formations and genetic medicine
to be able to create a and fortify
molecular diagnostics laboratory on
research
thank you very much
thank you so much aditayo and adi kunle
for your
insight so
the graduates from our previous programs
in africa have not only gone through
this hands-on training
that dr adito just spoke about but also
applied their learning to their own
research projects for example
dr ayorin de here who is from the
university of ibadan
proposed this project on differential
transcriptome expression of malaria
and semi-immune adults to a plasmodium
defects
sporozoid challenge in a similar way
we had miyambo who also proposed a
research project
on in-depth transcriptomic analysis to
determine the response to inhibition of
pkna
and pknb by m tuberculosis
so this entire training program
is designed to make sure that you can
first learn
and then apply the logic to your own
independent research here
are more examples from participants of
our previous programs who have also
given their
feedback for example king stone was part
of two of our previous or mixed logic
programs
in africa last year and he shares that
he had a great experience
with the program that we conducted
so the aim of the omics logic
program and the training is to help you
towards your goal of working on your own
independent research project
and we have some example projects on the
side with which you first learn and then
you can also propose your own proposal
and we will
offer you the mentor support that dr
aditya pointed
out so we are going to be starting from
this existing
resources and in a minute
i will show you the examples on the site
so i'm sure that by now everybody has
already signed up to the server
and to the edut bio bioinfo portal
if you have not already we will also be
emailing you
again all of these details and you can
then sign up at your own pace
so how to register for the upcoming
program so that you can get access to
this training
the resources and the mentor support
so i will now take you through the
different steps
so we have a portal or what we call
a landing page and i'm sure that many of
you must have already signed up
here as you are joining today's webinar
session
so this is the link again once you
register
on this link you would receive an email
from our team in africa and the email
address
would be
africa pine dot bio
so let me again post that email id in
the chat
africa pine dot bio for any questions
related
to this upcoming program and as you see
here
you have a form here so if you have not
already signed up
please sign up via this link
and once you're signed in you are
registered you will receive all the
details for
payment via email and once you're
already signed in
you will have access to this first
resource so
as we already showed you that you will
get access to edut bioinfo which is a
first platform right
so if you come under events you will
have
an even where you can see the omics
logic
africa program so i'll just give it a
minute to load back
okay so now you have the nigeria
training basic
so if you're already logged into the
server you can go ahead and check out
this page
it will leave you to this page right
here i am not sharing the link again
in the chat because this is the link you
get
access to once you're already registered
for the program
so once you're here you can see there
are several sections right here
first is the forum so the forum is where
we
share different communication links with
our participants
moving ahead we have the courses right
here
and we also have several different
projects
so the first step to sign up for this
is to register here
now i would like to invite uh dr mohit
to say a few more words dr muth if you
can go ahead and
talk some more thank you
thank you okay let me share my screen
all right hello everyone a very good
evening
today we discuss the introductory
training that is designed
to infer biological insights from big
data
and gain in-depth knowledge from guided
workflows that you saw
courses and publication based project
examples
so beeps also mentioned that how we can
translate from this training to working
and doing a project
so i would like to share a few slides
about
that so to broadly describe the
application of ngs data
these methods are commonly used in
variety of biomedical research that you
heard about today and also clinical
projects where
large data are beginning to be more and
more available
so one of the objective of the omics
logic program
is to be able to develop an independent
project
or gain experience from working on a
project
with a research team so the next step
after learning about the technology is
to apply those skills
to a real research project
so um we follow a a particular
curriculum
and use talk we talked about the omics
logic program and
we learned about how this is actually
working for our participants all around
the globe
so to describe you this in a nutshell
we are what we will try to learn in this
entire experience
is to be to understand how modern
biology
is shaping is shaped by data and these
analytical thinking
to develop that and also to learn from
research project
examples applying advanced
bioinformatics to real problems
to to gain an understanding a broad
understanding of how
high throughput technology and ohmic
studies
work and also to gain solid ground in
omics processing
analysis and machine learning and in the
end
when you have all this information and
all these skill sets and
understanding of the technology it is to
connect those dots
so to explore system biology to
multi-omics integration
as i as i was telling you that the
application
is pretty important to complete this
training because you start from
you start from the understanding of
these technology
and then you want to do work on your own
research
idea so that idea could be about
oncology could be about virology could
be about neuroscience
or biotechnology where you are also you
also saw
the application in the micro microbial
world
and also again because we are using
these data science and machine learning
techniques
so that those are the research areas
that we are focusing on
and as you saw that these are the people
who whom we have worked with
uh who whom we have worked as a research
fellowship program
and they came up with uh these uh
club by collaborating amongst themselves
came up with this research
ideas and they were able to work
together as a group
and come up with a project that has
objectives results and conclusion
so one of the benefits of doing this and
uh like you saw several of these
examples
is to be able to complete these projects
as a part of research and learn
by by later presenting this in
prestigious conferences
leading to poster presentations
conferences
and to start this uh journey i mean um
you you start with the basic
understanding and then you move towards
uh application and then publication
and so on so this is a com so that the
entire thing could be showcased in your
profile
you can put it as uh in your cv
uh and connect with people whom uh you
can you
have this research interest using this
community
uh so thank you uh for this uh for
for the time and uh i would like to pass
it on to biepsha to talk further about
the
program thank you thank you everyone
uh thank you yeah maybe i'll just wrap
this up so muhit please
put back the screenshot of the last
slide
sure
so again we do have um our
final uh kind of part of this
webinar we would love to learn a little
bit more about your background
so i've started a poll where we are
asking three questions
first one what is your educational
background
high school bachelor's degree master
degree
phd or other number two
what are your research interests
infectious diseases virology oncology
neuroscience machine learning data
science or other
and number three what are you looking
forward to learn from this session
so from this upcoming program uh brush
up
on my bioinformatics skills acquire
knowledge about bioinformatics or
interact and collaborate with other
experts in this
field so if you have any comments
about this webinar about the topics that
we have covered
please put your questions in the chat
box
if you do not have any questions we ask
that you
fill out this poll so that way we will
learn more about your background and we
will be able to
tailor the sessions that we are planning
more to your background and
interests we will be working with our
team in nigeria to make sure that we
collect this information
and we share this information back with
all of you so that you're aware of other
participants that have
joined this session today and for those
of you that have submitted your
registration
you can also submit your
request to get a recording or the
recording will be posted
on our social media including on youtube
where you can watch the full recording
of the session
and of course for any questions as beeps
are mentioned here in the chat box
you can email us at africa pine dot
bio
and there are also an option to send
questions in the whatsapp group aditaya
would you like to mention anything else
about how to reach to you
and how to ask any questions
any questions can be sent to that email
address at african powder bao
or the whatsapp group the most most
participants will have joined
where the email we sent to them or any
other channels
our phone number my phone number is also
probably in the email email address
email messages we sent to the email
addresses
so any of this i'm always available to
answer any question and
resolve any queries thank you so here we
have a question
i am a graduate of ecotourism and
wildlife management
federal university of technology cure
akure i don't know how to say that sorry
how can i implement this in
ecological management and monitoring so
i think that's a very interesting
question
ecological management wildlife
management the resources that we think
of
as forests and untouched nature natural
reserves
actually play a major role in
for example habitat for species
that carry various diseases for example
ebola virus hiv stars cove 2
are all thought to be coming from bats
or maybe through bats through some other
intermediate species
as the human population grows
and we start emptying the
natural habitat endangering those
we will see more and more interaction
between humans
and some of those species that have been
up until now
remote and separated from this
interaction
so that direct contact is very dangerous
because
our immune systems are unprepared for
the types of viruses that have been
co-evolving with these
other species for thousands of years
so i think that's one important area
where some of this
bioinformatics and big data plays a
major role
and has direct relationship to the
topics that you're studying
uh saheed uh but other than that you
know in preservation and
characterization
we think you know humans think that we
know a lot about different species out
there and you know what they're like and
things like that
and so if you read about some history of
natural research
you will see how this estimate
of how many species are out there has
been constantly been
upgraded by many fold from originally
people thought
that maybe there's a hundred thousand to
you know millions today
so i think this research is ongoing and
we will see
more and more new interesting variation
in the life
around us and we will be able to learn
from these new types of evidence that is
collected through this type of
phenotypic and
molecular data about the unique uh
properties of these new species
okay uh haruna is saying in 2016 i was
involved in a study that involved
next-generation sequencing but we had to
move our samples outside nigeria for
analysis i would love to know
the current availability of ngs services
in nigeria
well i think as you mentioned many
people outsource
because there's a lack of infrastructure
as was pointed out by adekunle
and others that you know requires you to
maybe send your samples for sequencing
and also
rely on experts for analysis and so this
is an attempt
to build up this kind of capacity within
nigeria
to make sure that you can do both
sequencing and there are several labs
that i know of that do sequencing
but also also the analysis you know many
times when you outsource the analysis
all you get is process data back or some
kind of a report
but that data contains a lot of
information that typically is not
reported on
so the infrastructure that we are
seeking to establish with our
computational resources
and with training is essentially to help
make that a reality
in nigeria so we would love to learn
more haruna about your
you know current employment and where
you are so that we can coordinate how
this can be done for your organization
is asking what possible ways can i
integrate bioinformatics in a research
around
environmental friendly and sustainable
crop production in nigeria
i think a very very important topic
right here
so as you know that crops
and established crops especially
have been bred over hundreds of years
as a result of the changes in the
climate
and the changes in the demand we need to
adapt
and that breeding process is very time
consuming right the selective breeding
process is very time consuming
so given the availability of resources
given the
changes in the climate and given the
type of production levels that we expect
to
serve the growing population we need to
adapt
and what we know about the current crops
is that for example we have a project on
our website
about potato crops
potato has different levels of tolerance
for heat
and for drought and that project
explores how you can study
transcriptomic variation among the
different crops to understand
what might be the possible way to
benefit from some crops that maybe have
lower production but higher tolerance or
the other way around
so i think that's an insight into that
question
saheed is asking how can you make this
course available at a cheaper rate for
undergraduates
excellent question beeps say if you
could post the link
we annually allocate about twenty
thousand dollars
towards scholarships and we would love
for you to take
uh this opportunity to fill out this
form
it's a financial assistance request
where we will evaluate your background
and your need
and we ask for some references from your
educational coordinators or faculty to
make this program more affordable for
you so
if you could please post the link fill
out this form
and you can actually fill that out and
get a discount
through filling that out also
i am an animal biotechnologist a
question by biola
with keen interest in exploring simple
and complex inheritance traits
of animals i know bioinformatics is a
major key tool in solving this i will
appreciate in this workshop
and workshop can be of help so
i think that exactly you know
that's the right direction there are
simple and more
complex traits they're associated with
inheritance in other words genetic
profiling
and study of genomic data could be very
helpful
myself i'm not an expert in animal
biotechnology so
i would love to hear more about the
specifics of your interest so we can
help develop
resources also related to that topic
and there are many biotechnology related
data sets that we will explore
throughout the program in fact one of
the
pieces of this program is going to
different resources where you can find
publicly available data sets
start exploring those and understand how
other people around the world are using
this kind of omics data
to study a variety of different projects
so we'll go through that and one of the
places i would think of
is you could go to ncbi the national
center for biotechnology information
where you can find all kinds of data on
these types of projects
francis is asking i am concluding a phd
in chemistry where i am applying machine
learning to predict the impact and
incidences of naturally occurring
toxins in humans and environment how can
this program help
well i think that's an excellent start
if you're already applying
machine learning to a data set based on
chemical properties of different toxic
molecules
what you will find is that the toxic
molecules
interact with the human
organs tissues cells in different ways
and i think that one part of information
are the physical chemical properties
of the molecules themselves another
source of data
is how that reaction happens when you
try and apply them to different tissue
cells and even animal models so there's
data like that out there
there's also gene expression data
protein expression data
so you can learn about how the
interaction happens
to get more insights into not only
the general properties but the actual
specific
properties of those molecules so i think
we would love to
talk more about this if you want to
reach out to us again
write us an email to africa at pine dot
bio
at the time was mentioning that for
participants having issues with payment
via
paystack please send me an email on how
we can assist you in making direct
payments
so again payments is something that is
being handled by our team in nigeria via
paystack
so if you could email them directly you
will see there are different options
that they can
custom match for your for you to be able
to do that
icra is also asking from pakistan how
can we register for this course in
cheaper packages so there's actually two
ways as i also
mentioned you can request a scholarship
which could be a significantly cheaper
for you to pay
but also if you do not have the funds
there is a lot of material that we offer
on all of these resources that you can
gain access to for completely free of
charge
so we ask that all of you that have
registered on the educational portal
start exploring the introduction to
bioinformatics course and some other
courses that are free
on the coding platform there are some
free courses as well
and you can also get access to the
platform as a demo
account also completely free of charge
so you can understand some of the
conceptual steps
in analyzing big data as well
so hopefully that helps
our wall kabir is also
mentioning something about payments um
okay so uh adekunle is asking that i
mention
for renee if you can reach out to
arakuni via whatsapp
so he can help resolve the payment by
providing a
dollar payment link and
for the course certificates yes
each course will have a certificate
and that certificate is something that
you can link to you will also get a
certificate for the full program in the
end as well
and so we will you know share those
certificates also
at the end of the program especially for
those of you that continue to work
on independent projects so
you will see in our blog post many of
our
uh exceptional people that have done
independent projects
have continued to be featured by our
team
so that you can gain exposure so that's
another opportunity
there i have a question here
from emmanuel uh he says that i'm
interested in metagenomics it is a phd
student will this course help me to use
bioinformatics
to study microbes population dynamics in
a polluted media
that is under bioremediation while help
to pinpoint
enzymes involved in the degradation
process
and pinpoint organisms that produce
specific substances that have aided
the biodegradation of pollutants so
that's a research question there
yeah so that's an excellent question you
know metagenomic sequencing
is the approach of taking a
sample directly from the environment
and trying to understand species
diversity
and richness and compare those between
different conditions
so when you speak about direct
metagenomic
16s ribosomal rna amplicon sequencing
that gives you taxonomic composition it
allows you to see
what the population of microbes in a
given sample
looks like so if you have a normal
versus some toxic environment and you
want to compare the two
you can compare diversity so what
how many different species you have and
species richness or
how abundant are specific species now
from that comparison you can infer
some elements of what you're speaking
about because ultimately if you want to
understand
what those species do which is you know
specific metabolites they produce etc
you actually want to not only understand
what genome do they have but you also
want to understand what do they produce
so you want to actually look at
metatranscriptomic
or metabolomic data from such
environments and that's a little bit
different from just simple
amplicon metagenomic data ultimately we
discuss a lot of these concepts
in our metagenomics training courses you
can get started from the introduction to
metagenomics which is a
free link a free course and once you
cover that you'll understand the
different approaches to sequencing
and what that information can give you
so i think that's going to be a good
start
and then you can find the appropriate
data set to ask
downstream questions you know depending
on what kind of data set you have access
to
okay well let's briefly review the poll
results it looks like
the majority of you have a master's
degree
of some kind and the second largest
category are bachelor degree holders
in terms of research interest it seems
that predominantly
infectious diseases is the largest group
here
which is exciting to know because i
think it's a pressing
issue obviously now in the time of the
pandemic this is an important one as
well
and in terms of what you're looking
forward to learn from the session
it looks like many of you are interested
in acquiring knowledge about
bioinformatics and that means that many
of you are probably just getting started
so i think that's
exactly what we intended for this
webinar to do
so it's great to see that you are all
falling under this category
again thank you for joining today this
is something that we have been looking
forward to we will have another
upcoming webinar so you can register
in the link that was provided by the
tile
in that link you will see that you can
you will start receiving emails so look
out for the next email
about another free webinar that will be
coming up
and in that next webinar we will hope to
do a little bit more hands-on
so all of you that have joined today
this is not going to be a repeat of the
same thing it's going to be a little bit
more practical
and please please complete the
introduction to bioinformatics which is
a free course by that time
so that we can have a more fruitful
discussion in our next webinar
and as that italian mention here that's
going to be january 11th
so just in a few days
all right thank you